hey everyone I would like to take a
little bit of time to discuss unity 2020
with you the current state of political
affairs in the United States is one that
nobody who's tasted even a glimpse of
enlightenment wants waking up on
November 4th and having either a 77 year
old or a 74 year old who are visibly
experiencing cognition issues and are
extremely polarizing both of them is not
healthy for maximizing the flourishing
of the entire United States and actually
the world at large the United States
right now has the opportunity to be a
role model for the rest of the world the
entire world right now
is watching what the United States is
going to do the statistics are extremely
clear that the entire planet is sick of
political corruption the entire planet
knows that people especially in
political offices that are especially
incumbents are relentlessly take
King bribes money under the table
self-dealing for themselves rather than
serving the people of their country now
regarding how to properly architect a
justice and a truth and a sense making
apparatus for modernity that is still to
be as a team figured out yet we have the
opportunity to be a role model in the
sense of rather than having this
legislative gridlock that has been
continued over time and two extremely
polarized parties I would even like to
propose that rather than completely
shutting down everything that China has
done we could actually maybe take
something useful from what China has
done one person from the center left and
one person from the center right as a
team is a very smart strategy it's
actually a strategy that has the
potential to represent the exact ethos
of our reality when we have two people
that can act literally as a dialectic
where they're constantly playing tennis
with each other it enables a very
well-thought-out decision making process
and critical thinking process and Andrew
yang and bill McRaven are two
exceptional candidates for
Unity 2020 we have the opportunity right
now to get politically engaged behind
something that is actually meaningful
that actually tugs at our hearts and
makes a smile it solves monkey politics
were sick of monkey politics were sick
of corruption and we're sick of gridlock
and we're sick of tribalism and poles
there's a big exhausted majority of a
huge exhausted majority the amount of
friends that I have that say that they
will not be participating in this
election because it's - its AIDS versus
malaria and they refuse to participate
the amount of times that we've heard
that from our friends is so egregiously
hi you are now presented with an
opportunity articles of unity dot org
will give you all of the details you
need to see for now go there go there
and read and go there and share and sign
up sign up with your time get behind
this if you actually want change the way
is to do it like what Bret Weinstein did
which was to take a step forward into
actually entrepreneurially creatively
artistically organizationally provide a
solution and if we can get people that
are heretics that are having Orthodox
thinking styles
if we can get them behind this as well
things like the IDW getting behind this
we can experience more and more success
with where we want to go I want to give
you I want to give you something quick
to talk to to feed on if you have
someone that's courageous if you have
someone that's capable if you have
someone that's patriotic if you have
these guys governing as a team
discussing every decision you have a
solution that is jam-packed ready to go
and serve you a success I think check it
out get behind it remember the number
one thing that you can do right now is
actually get involved that's really it
that's all that that's all that I want
to say it's a great idea
go forth behind it get a collective of
Gnostic people people that are
self-realized that realize the the
nature of reality that realize how we
can provide entrepreneurial creative
scientific spiritual solutions to the
complexity of our world participate in a
game be style architecture of our future
and engage yourself don't wake up
thinking screw this on November 4th get
behind it now get behind it now and
share it and let's see where we can go
from here so I love you very much thank
you everybody for tuning in and get
behind this go check it out articles of
unity dot work sign up share it and
let's provide the solution
to so many of our problems let's do it